okay so uh let me just check if we are
live seems that we
are nice we're getting some people in
the
chat let's
go all
right ah there we go okay had some lag
there so so uh hello everyone and
welcome to the first event we are
organizing uh through our good friends
uh uh the improve app and here we have
uh one of the founders of mof clay hello
Clay how is
everything everything is great very
excited for this event and uh you know I
want to give a special shout out to
everyone that's supported us so far with
this platform we're seeing some some
great results and enthusiasm and uh we
want to you know keep bringing fun
events like this to you guys so let us
know what you think
yeah and uh this is a much much bigger
event than I than I even hop that we
would have facing world number five in
chess uh in in a simultaneous exhibition
not something you get to see every day
uh so just uh a quick quick hello to
everyone who joined us in the chat R Al
Shan janul goren gulan Avis XA Isaac
Barber uh a75 Humanity Festina L met
yoban Ron HK Ahmed Bluebird AMV hus
insane dude uh asking no ala cam yes ala
will be joining us also with Cam uh I
believe in some maybe 15 to 20 minutes
before the the start of the actual event
so so far uh we have um how many people
joined uh okay so we have one two three
four five
six okay so 13 16 yeah uh four I believe
14 people are in the Simo so far and we
have some very decent ratings here uh
even some 1900 1800 we even have a
gentleman
Mori uh tributing the great morphe with
2140 so could even be a very nice
challenge for alza uh I'm hoping uh
everyone will be a challenge I mean I I
can't imagine what it's like to play
against 30 people uh sorry well any any
amount of people for that matter I think
once I tried playing against two end
already was very
challenging yeah I I have no idea I
can't imagine how you I'm a I was a
professional tennis player and I'm very
used to playing one person and it's a
duel I can't imagine trying to take on
20 people at once and that's kind of
what we were going for when we made that
funny uh Chuck Norris video if anyone
follows us on social media and Ali reso
was just beating up everyone that comes
his
way uh people in the chat asking what is
the team entry code uh for the moment
the team entry code is uh specified only
for the top 20 improvers of the Improv
team so only the top 20 will be able to
face
alza thank you Bluebird AMV that is that
is very much
true uh and for those of you who have
not received it for uh for any reason
you have it in the in the uh in the team
uh page on Lees uh so there you you can
just check it out you have the link and
everything uh it says uh yeah someone
asked is that the link where we play or
where we watch or both yes it is you
play there you watch there you can do uh
everything there uh but unless you have
the password you will not be able to
join uh of
course so uh clay uh What uh what's uh
what's been up with uh with the app I I
heard we had some good news uh we uh
only could uh receive people via their
cell phone number now we can also
receive people via email so that's a big
plus yep yeah so obviously I don't think
we how many International users would uh
prefer to use their email than phone
numbers and we got a few negative
reviews because of that so apologies
there we we worked as hard as we could
to come out with the email
implementation uh so now you can sign up
with that we also have our scholarship
program which we're really excited to
announce so improve right now you know
basically we're a we're a
self-improvement platform that that
covers many different topics right now
we're in chess tennis and pickle ball
and we're actually sponsoring a tennis
player to go back on tour uh as one of
my teammates at UCLA and he is competing
in an International Tournament right now
and he's in the semi-finals as we speak
so we can be cheering him on and that
scholarship program we want to take that
same concept and bring it to chess so
you know we want to sponsor aspiring
chess players we want to help them live
out their dreams of you know becoming
great chess players and also even if you
don't want to become you know a
professional chess player we want to
help you get better at chess so if you
simply can't afford the subscription for
our app we want you to apply for a
scholarship tell us your story and we
hope to help you get on your way to
becoming the chess player you want to
be yeah and so far uh I'm I mean as as
much as I've seen all the reviews are
pretty much positive uh people are are
chipping in on how to improve what what
could be done better uh so I I I like
the the progress that that has been made
so far
yeah and hopefully we got a lot a lot
more to come and again we we want to
hear from you guys especially you know
how did you like this event how do you
like the stuff that we're doing the
content that we're creating um you know
I don't know if if you want to spoil
this for your users uh Gad but we're
hoping to uh have aad matur himself do
you know a cool series about telling his
experience of some of the most
culturally significant chess games uh
that he's that you know that that he
believes in um and so you know to kind
of bring stories like that to help grow
the game and help enrich you know all
the people that that play the game
culturally I mean we love that we just
want to help grow the sport yeah I mean
there there definitely are some games
that uh for example for me once I I saw
a certain game I I just fell in love
with chess and
uh I never never got away from it so
it's uh I mean there are many of course
but I'm I'm sure everyone has that one
game for them that really made it
special yeah and that's what we want to
do is just you know allow people
to to gain insight into what has
motivated you know great chess players
like yourself or Ali Resa or anyone else
that you know what what was that point
that got them to be so interested in the
game and and to dedicate so much of
their life to it yeah we'll be able to
ask alza that um I'm hoping he will be
able to answer some of the questions
from the from the people playing and
also from the people in the chat
uh I don't know how how much he will be
struggling with these opponents maybe he
will maybe the games will be so Fierce
he will simply not be able to answer but
we'll see maybe we can do it maybe we
can do it afterwards yeah I hope he's I
hope he's very focused yeah I'm sure he
has to be he's preparing for for a
really big event uh part of a part of a
f Grand Prix uh if he wants to if he
wants to be part of the next candidates
tournament so this will be this will be
very good prepar ation for him yeah and
um you know for for me who's you know
I'm I'm mostly I'm a casual chess fan I
would say could could you give me a
little bit of Ali Reza's
resume do you know kind of where where
he stands up right now as opposed to the
best players in the world and kind of
what his results this year did he play
the the FI World Championship that just
happened the sorry the what the Fe is it
Fay FID yeah yeah it's it's F but it's
not the the world
Championship okay he played in the
previous cycle to qualify for the for
the title of Challenger but U he he
didn't manage to qualify and he's not
actually playing that much now at the
moment he's uh uh taking it easy uh he
didn't even played the World Cup uh
simply because it's a a event that
lasted over a month so he he he wasn't
interested in investing all that much
time in chess so we'll see what he does
with the the next event I mean it's uh
it'd be interesting how how Fierce he
would be if he actually you know devoted
all of his time in chess but that's
probably one of his uh top secrets uh he
didn't uh start playing chess when he
was like three uh or maybe four like
some of the prodigies that you've heard
of he actually started when he was I
believe uh 8 years
old uh and uh his father just didn't
want to put any pressure on him or or
you know even teach him the rules I
believe his brother taught him the rules
when he was like eight and some parents
even consider that's too late to start
you know some some children are already
playing for 5 years so how would you
compete with them uh but you know ala
shows that it doesn't
matter yeah I I know that story very
very well from tennis as well and I
think it's it's great to see players
evolve out of you know passion for the
game obviously there's there's so many
great players that have been playing
since a very young age and maybe have
gone to all the you know best coaches
andies or whatever but to see someone
really kind of grow their ability in an
organic way just purely out of a love
for the game I mean I feel like that's
how I was with tennis too and I just
love to see that I mean it it provides
so much more emotion to me than uh just
watching someone who's kind of been a
robot their whole life playing the game
yeah so at what age did you start uh
with Dennis I started about four but I
my route was a little bit unconventional
because I actually went to a real school
like a you know normal in-person school
I went to college and and then I and
then I finally went to play on the pro
tour um but you know I had a lot of
interests in my life besides being
besides being a tennis player despite
kind of you know my dream to be one of
the best tennis players in the world I
didn't want kind of to be completely
consumed by that which which I see with
a lot of my colleagues it's like you
know they come off tour and you know
it's just kind of like what do I do now
H yeah yeah and any other uh plans that
you can reveal for for the improve uh
aside from pickable tennis and chess uh
maybe for the somewhat near
future yeah we have a kind of General
Health school coming out um it's it's a
little it's more geared towards women um
to to get a little bit more uh female
users on our app uh so that's going to
be a women's health school that we're
doing with sort of a celebrity
gynecologist um and a TV we're doing it
in conjunction with a TV show that was
one of the most popular shows on Ellen
DeGeneres's platform um a couple years
ago so we're excited about that and then
we're also coming out with a dance
school with a world-renowned gymnast and
D dance dancer um so and that school
will go over all different types of
dance um I mean unfortunately I I can't
even explain all of them because I don't
know them myself but we're going to it's
going to be a very in-depth dance school
and uh anyone that is interested in
either of those topics topics I hope
that you continue to follow us and uh
you know join them when they come out in
quarter one of next year yeah and I I
just wanted to mention that uh uh it it
really does seem like today where we
have U sort of uh infinite content
creators like everyone is creating
content like there's no person anything
you do is basically content creation uh
it really uh you know we really need
some some way of curating the content
like taking away from all that which is
created and you know handpicking all the
good stuff and you know presenting that
somehow and improve trying to do just
that I believe it it it does have a very
special place in the Chess World yeah I
totally agree with that and and that's
you know one of the main value
propositions of our app is there's no
one way to learn there's never just you
know as a competitive athlete myself
like it's not like I just took from one
coach or one Creator like the way that I
really improved was I watched tons of
videos from all different types of
people I tried to go to as many coaches
as possible and learn what they had to
to offer um and so we're trying to
curate the world's content of good
content you know a Gad mature signs off
on every piece of content that's in our
school but you may see an interview from
Magnus Carlson you may see an article
written by you know a chess editor
that's that's very very high level um
it's all this different types of content
that will help you improve because we
don't think that that one voice is
necessarily the best way to Improvement
yeah I I I created over 3,000 videos and
while I do have some nice ideas on how
to present maybe chess openings I I I
could handpick maybe three of my videos
that I would re re really
recommend uh and I I don't think any
creator has all the content that is
really worth
studying so you know yeah re really
curating it is the is the way to go yeah
totally um I see a couple people in the
chat that are just asking you know how
to participate so just to make that
clear um we started this you know the
promotions for this event probably about
a month ago and we asked people to climb
the ranks on the improve app and the top
20 people on the app um are included in
this event it's it has nothing to do
with your chess rating you could be a
complete beginner player but if you
spent a lot of time over the past month
improving your chess game and getting
better then you would be selected for
this
event yeah and uh so far we have okay
there's still 15 minutes we have
uh I believe 12 people
in so I'm just going to check real
quickly and why don't we send another
message because we have 21 members uh
total in the improved team message means
that everyone joined only not everyone
joined the the Simo I'm going to resend
it once
more sorry just let me do this real
quickly there we
go ala is 20 872 very nice very nice
yeah I think I'm 800 right now
800 is that like uh you've just
registered or you you actually did some
playing I've done I've done some playing
played I've been playing decent amount
over the past
month yeah yeah and pretty good pretty
good
guys what do you what what do you go for
with
white
um I would move it well depends but uh
I'd move uh two spots two spots uh
forward on the queen side or on the
king's side okay is that a is that a big
mistake grabbing the center that's uh
the the the most important thing for for
you know starting out whether with pawns
or you know with pieces you can do it
either
way I mean pretty much pretty much
anything you play can be described as a
you know a brilliant approach if you
know what why you've played it so it
doesn't really matter what you actually
play um so I don't know is Will Ali Resa
be joining shortly if if if he's about
to join maybe we could uh do the
improved promo video for a sec before he
joins or what do you think about that
yeah yeah uh let me just load it
up
yeah Marco uh the the app is called
improve and it's available on mobile
phone we we are hoping to have a web
version uh coming out soon but um you
know the the entries for this event
right now are closed but we hope you
download the app and uh improve your
chess game on it and hopefully you can
be included in the next
one
okay let me just check
something
all right so we should be starting in
about 10
minutes
code is fake simultaneous no I can
assure you that this is not a fake Simo
we uh have been planning this for about
a month and uh you know all all of our
users are people that have been on the
app for a long time and have shown
progress
so we hope that for the next event
that's
you uh de vagna I am Klay Thompson I am
the founder of the improve app which
we're putting on the siml today with
agad matur and Ali Resa and we should be
starting in about 10
minutes
sorry having some issues here will just
take a second to fix it oh
good happy to answer any other uh
questions in the chat while we're
waiting
Ario 1111 I really appreciate that it's
I mean those are the types of comments
that make
us motivated to to do this to to do this
project I mean we've been working on
this for about four years now we just
went live um in July so three months ago
and we're seeing such great user
feedback and reviews I mean again that
that comment is exactly the types of
things that that gives me chills and
makes me feel great and uh we really
appreciate appreciate that hope to do a
lot more fun stuff for the chess
Community Captain Nautilus I am 31 years
old getting up
there app is available on the Play Store
maros 6 yes we're we're available on iOS
and um the Google Play store again we
have plans to launch the web version
coming
soon sorry the the weirdest thing just
happened uh since I'm using Zoom to
communicate with you zoom said that I
have to use a full version of Zoom if I
want to talk to
you longer so I had to upgrade quickly
love that quick quick upgrade yeah it
was uh you know it happens what are you
going to
do yeah found things I found um I
founded a improve is a an improvement
platform so we have a chess School a
pickle ball school and a tennis school
and we're coming out with many more
schools um we hope to be an open
platform form in the future I was a
professional tennis player i' I've
played chess since I was you know six
years old as far as just very casually
but uh you know I haven't played
probably in 14 years since then so yeah
I'm I'm very beginner in chess as I said
earlier my my ELO rating on chess.com is
800 right now I am by no means a
competent chess player but uh I know
quite a bit about Improvement and you
know being a professional athlete and
being around a lot of professional
athletes I you know I respect the game
of chess and I want to help grow the
game of chess as well as every other
topic that we have on the
platform Felix dog says why not use
Discord I could agree with that again
yeah uh haven't uh because I've I've
been using Zoom for so long and now it
just popped in during stream I just
thought it was the you
know the the simplest way to do it but I
only got it for one month and I will
will obviously be switching switching to
Discord if Discord has it uh you
know uh for free uh on infinite although
uh I don't know if they if they
do they do really yeah I think they do I
use Discord with my friends and we uh
play video games and hang out together
and you talk for for a long time yeah we
talk for a long time oh okay yeah jokes
on me then
um why did friend zone TV why did you
really start improve as I've mentioned
um you know it's kind of based on my
experiences as someone that had a dream
for myself to be a tennis player um and
kind of our slogan is become the person
you want to be so we hope to cover a
variety of different topics and you know
help people on that journey to become
the person they want to be because
there's so much content out there right
now uh it's kind of overwhelming and you
don't know really who to trust so we
want to kind of lay it out for you in a
very structured way with content from
creators that you trust and you know
guide you along that path to becoming
the person you want to be or you know
becoming the chess player you want to be
becoming the tennis player you want to
be whatever it
is uh Ario 111 my favorite tennis player
of all time is a man named vus gerelus
who played in kind of the Mac Andro era
um and now my favorite tennis player is
Daniel Medvedev love that
guy I I I I I don't really follow tennis
all that much so I don't know who that
is is he like really really
good yeah he he's the number three
player in the world right now he won the
US Open two years ago uh he lost in the
finals of the US Open this year to Novak
jokovic which I'm sure you know him yeah
yeah I I do know
Novak
do do you have a favorite chess
player yeah Ali Resa oh of course ala
yeah uh was someone someone asked uh
what what games uh were you playing with
your team or with your friends I mean
yeah I've I've been a video game player
for a long time uh right now they just
did a a relaunch of Counter Strike which
I played for the first time when I was
probably I don't know 10 so we've been
playing a lot of that counter- strike
too uh I'm also uh you know quite a high
ranked League of Legends player I hit
Master tier on Legends of run Tera uh
the card game I know you play a lot of
he or used to play a lot of hearstone
again yeah I I used to now I just maybe
throw in a Battlegrounds here and there
yeah okay I think we I think we're
having GZA let me just
check
uh
there we
go hey
guys uh let me just check oh uh I see
him I see him on Zoom yeah I also see
him I just don't see him uh I don't see
him on my stream which is odd I not see
him on your stream
either I have also disappeared yeah you
have also disappeared that is quite
strange let me just fix that real
quickly
uh Captain Nautilus I love yanx Center
he's also one of my favorite favorite
players right
now sorry there we go ah yeah yeah when
three people join then it uh sort of
mess you can take my face away if you
want think people have seen enough of me
oh we can kind of see Ali
res yeah yeah no no no he's uh we're
we're getting the the wrong one but no
I'm I'm going to fix it now
sorry problems with OBS
always okay let me just do it like this
Simple and
Clean hello
Goron give a special shout out to Goran
he's been very helpful in uh the
creation of the
school yeah a lot of work with the gmor
Goran is the man Goran is the
man ala are you fully prepared to take
on this Army of
improvers yeah I heard they're pretty
good yeah they are we we even have uh
players over
2,000 I think I think only one but uh
yeah still it's uh much more than I
expected I never did online Simo so it
will be first time also this experience
you never did an online Simo not even
like no
okay do have you have you prepared any
special
openings um I hope I hope I'm getting
all white yeah yeah you are uh no I'm
pretty sure you can set that up yeah it
says host color white okay that that's
good
news but um but it's of course easier
than over real life simal I think
because you don't need to move around
you just sit behind the
computer yeah but if it lasts like maybe
two hours then it can be pretty tiring
to sit to just
sit yeah but I because whenever I play
Simon in real life my neck will hurt so
much because I have to look down and for
two hours I have to look down and move
around so it's not that easy so but
we'll see maybe little bit tougher yeah
in 2016 when Kasparov visited cra he
held a simal in CPR and he I think he
took on maybe 20 or 30 people also and
he was scorching hot like it was so hot
it was uh uh and he played it for like 4
hours it was uh incredible that he could
just you know play for so long in the in
the scorching Sun it was pretty it was
sick yeah yeah he's hours L yeah yeah
he's a he's a
beast he likes s Simons I think like
whenever I see him for instance in Grand
Chesters we always play first Simon and
then he's always there he's motivated
more than everyone else yeah he he came
to crush he came to crush everyone yeah
yeah yeah I think uh yeah okay he does a
lot of sim I think y pogar she does
really a lot of simal and uh I know some
people do too but I think two of them
like do the most in like in
person okay okay I need to do I need to
accept people because I have a Buton
that people are trying to join and I
have to accept
them uh I don't think you have to accept
them uh where you where are they trying
to join the team or the
Simo in the Simo uh
page for instance in your YouTube
channel I see your page but I have the
Blue Tick button I should accept them
you don't have this but I have this
okay uh should I accept them but so far
have you accepted people no I didn't
accept anyone no no no then you don't
accept them it's for it's probably
people who don't have uh who don't have
a password to
join because they have the same name as
in your okay we'll see how it will go
because I have to start the games or yes
yes you
do U oh maybe this is the button that I
should press to start the game right ah
yeah probably I've never I've never held
a assal unleashes or anywhere
else yeah yeah people said that it
hasn't started for them so you are
probably the host you you have to start
them okay I'm accepting everyone ah okay
yeah yeah now everyone's getting joined
in very nice ah okay yeah yeah yeah okay
so we we've learned
something okay there's there are 20
people I click the start button should
we start yes we definitely should okay
do you need uh full time to focus or do
you mind also talking a little bit no we
can't talk it's okay do you see the
games uh let me just check uh which one
do you okay so first okay first is ger
Gerard of barbar badia yes yes and he's
very quick he obviously prepared ah so
uh in online you don't have to play a
move and then play all the moves to get
back to this board you can like whenever
it's time to play you can just play huh
right exactly oh wow that's but I'm a
bit disappointed because I when I make
the move it doesn't go to next game Auto
oh yeah auto switch okay I I pressed the
button now it's good okay Gerard of
baradia is fully prepared here yeah I
actually thought he would go to to next
page uh will you you're going to open E4
on all of
them no I'm doing everything random but
I need to be quick right yeah you need
to be
quick I don't have so much time okay so
let me just check if there's an option
for uh yeah you can do it like
this yeah I I also thought that it would
present the next board once you made a
move it it does now for me ah it does
for you yes yeah maybe if I let me just
check this maybe if I can somehow
following okay sorry if there's a
watch games okay I believe I can do it
like this if I click watch games and you
switch to another game I think it will
follow
you okay the games are already getting
interesting some of
them baram from
Iran is baram does baram mean anything
in in in
Iran um I don't know exactly for sure
there should be some meaning
but um I'm not the expert I think
okay here we have cpex from
Germany going for
some I think for them it will be very
good strategy to work on my time oh you
did uh you didn't give yourself any
extra
time no no we have we both have 30
minutes but it's okay I think I could
handle it ah you you should have given
yourself a little bit more time maybe
maybe just uh you know maybe a 30 second
increment we'll see we'll see but okay
at least this will make it a bit more
fair for them yeah yeah exactly yeah I
didn't expect them to be playing so fast
you're playing really fast yeah every
everyone everyone's that they came here
to
kill it's inter this is this is very
fast SIM SIM for me because normally
everybody thinks for so long
but this is a
different in one of the boards the my
opponent should a bit take his time I
think
finishing I'm trying to I'm trying to
figure out uh if I can somehow get uh
because I clicked when I click on you I
click follow your games but then it
doesn't really follow your games it just
watches the current the the one that
you're currently making moves
on
okay yeah and the Mori you're uh
obviously tributing the great morphe uh
he is the one that is 2140 in Rapid so
we are expecting great things from
him ah okay I figured out how to do it
nice yeah very
nice yeah serious uh I I figured out
yeah it does not work as a show uh but
uh yeah there's a way to do it so these
guys are all member of the app right
yeah yeah top
20 maybe maybe we didn't get all the top
20 but
uh cronal is asking uh do you remember
your siml from
Zagreb yes that was one of the toughest
simers because it took I think like
three hours yeah and all of all of you
were playing it yeah yeah I I think I
finished in one of the
boards do you remember
do you remember the game for against the
young young dude iano
moic um I don't know the name
but the one that he he won very
nicely um I don't recall the name but I
I'm I remember that we lost in one of
the
boards well I heard we had uh our first
defeat already yeah yeah what or we have
a couple defeats
no no it was I think only one defeat
until now all right the first first
person is let just check which one which
one is it okay so it was a E4
E5 a nice R Lopez Knight captures on
e4 we playing so fast this is uh oh and
resigns which
game uh versus alen Bitcoin Watts no the
game that was finished was E4 E5 Knight
F3
F6 oh really or maybe two games are
finished now I don't know wow maybe he
resigned he just resigned maybe I don't
know I didn't see let me just check let
me just
check oh yeah also there's this one oh
F6 yeah
nice nice
nice I think the members should be think
more they're playing really fast I
thought maybe he was going to go for the
trick with Queen to A7 but no he he went
right for
it
yeah yeah uh I I think they they when
they see the time starting to drop that
they they get
nervous all right who do we have here
hold they're just working on my time
probably yeah H hor him
yeah this is the best game probably H
hor
96 all right it's it's the closest
game the best one uh the okay the one
that you say is the best I'm probably
going to cover that one on the
channel okay I finished another
game people should really start thinking
I don't know if they're watching the
stream I don't I don't think they have
the
time
okay so this one ended with Queen F7
okay oh this was a nice Scotch with a
with a queen H5 you're using the same
Checkmate in all the
games all right bottom bottom 19 is
taking his time
definitely
nice finish the another game against CeX
I
think yeah okay let me check let me
check let me
check yep you certainly
did oh it was a nice Rook Checkmate
huh
yeah okay so nice Queen trade you open
up the H file ah okay
okay
ah even that oh that's painful painful
for cpex from
Germany yeah is are the nationalities 20
different nationalities no uh some of
some of the people don't actually have
nationalities listed on their profile so
there's no way to know but uh I think
mostly yeah there are there are they are
different
nationalities
nice okay H H is playing really good I
should be careful here Mr Knight rituals
says uh that he loves you just just uh
you know thank you I also love him if
it's him there you go Mr night rituals
ala also also loves
you all right Gerard of baradia from
Barbados is really really hanging in
there it's good to know there are chess
players in Barbados yeah although people
can just click there from Barbados like
yeah like Andrew Tang like he says he's
from
Antarctica right
so but they have Olympia team I I
think I saw them in the Olympia one time
who Barb
Barbados team
yes what was this what was
this Knight Knight E6
oh morphe also is playing very good yeah
morphe always always plays
good he's our highest rated highest
rated
player yeah
exactly
did you watch the Queen's Gambit
show
yes what do you think it was good I
think it was very good to I think it's
one of it's the
only show that exactly says about the
life of a chess player professional
chess player and like it's not exactly
but it's kind of giving you a clue right
yeah so there are not so many good chess
chess movies or show shows so this is
one of the best of all time yeah and in
it's crazy it's really in general one of
the best series of all time not even in
chess yeah on Netflix
definitely yeah I just rewatched uh
Searching for Bobby Fisher and that's a
great movie too that that's also a very
great movie yeah that's uh really really
special one great actors I
mean and uh I mean I there was what
there was there was another movie Pawn
sacrifice which had lot of people
criticized it but I also liked it kind
of but a lot of people criticized it
yeah I couldn't uh I couldn't watch it I
for me it was too because I've read so
much on Bobby Fisher that I I could
never uh that's just not how I imagined
him and uh I know it's a movie okay
every director can has the you know the
artistic freedom to portray anyone the
way wants I I you know I just couldn't
couldn't watch it
right yeah also is I I I think if it's
not a propaganda esos also said it was a
very bad movie so ah okay I think he
said this but I'm not
sure yeah does some sound like something
he would say yeah
yeah okay but I'm also uh doing very
nice time
right I'm doing very good yes he's doing
very
good Simon coacho Simon coacho
Okay unfortunately had H collapsed
but it was a good game sorry let me just
check real quickly cpex collapsed uh
Jagger okay you've also dealt a very
nice Checkmate to jger
let me just quickly check that one okay
so it was
a oh crazy
stuff yeah very clean very
clean very clean but okay he did last 22
moves not not bad 23 with your
Checkmate
yes morphy morph I'm very impressed by
morphe yes he is he he is our star
player he's the he's also been a uh good
longtime user for improv so we
definitely shout him out and appreciate
that
nice yeah taking taking time but playing
very very
nicely
okay uh let me just check if any oh hot
honm also finished huh yeah yeah he went
too fast yeah it was
a let me just check
the I'm going to review all of them
slowly but I just want to see what
happened okay
okay I think we got a nice improved tip
from Resa here it's uh play a little bit
slower don't go too fast yes that's the
mistake that uh every beginner makes
but um chess is game of patience right
so it's so funny to me because I mean
you say that and you say it's such a
mistake and and yet you're known for
being one of the fastest chess players
in the world yeah I love that yeah um
when it's necessary you have to play
fast for instance when it's bleeds and
these kind kind of things you have to
play fast you should play fast so but
um I me in general you play chess to
learn P being patient I think that's the
point
so that's what I learned most maybe
about CH to be
patient it helps in life also I
think couldn't agree
more Mor Mor okay where is going to call
him morphe still going going very
strong
yeah when you uh you you started pretty
late with chess ala right like eight
years old yeah I was eight eight and a
half and what's the what's the first
thing you
started u connected in in which way like
uh you know solving puzzles did you just
play or read books or um mostly there
was a
I was playing online I when I started I
was playing with my brother and we were
playing online mostly so which is it was
not po so much popular at that time
there was like a some ples app yeah yeah
I remember it it's a it was a T-Mobile
app right right and now it's completely
gone but
yeah uh but it's we were playing there
247 so I remember I was escaping from
school to go play online going back home
and play online so that was the how we
started at what point uh were were you
better than your
brother um I think after one
year I think I started beating him and
he was very angry to me at me so but he
was beating me consistently before that
but after one year I think I catched up
to him ah and
yeah yeah who who knows if you'd be so
so so motivated if he wasn't beating you
up regularly yeah
exactly um I mean if it was not there I
would not even play chess probably so
it's all it's an interesting pattern I
mean I saw it a lot in tennis too as far
as you know the older brother obviously
is better young you know at the younger
ages but that kind of he beats up on the
younger brother and then motivates him
and then the younger brother is often
better I mean there's a lot of
professional tennis players especially
who are you know very very good who are
kind of the younger brother of of an
older brother who was decent but not
quite as good as they were yeah I I met
Brian Bros in Miami last year and they
were they had kind of similar story they
were T they are the best greatest double
tennis players and they I talked to them
a lot and it's helped me also to
understand their way and it I think we
had kind of same story but theyve
improved both so but my brother went
other ways so but they conquered the
double tennis W right oh yeah they were
they're the best doubles team to ever
play and they're also very very good
people um which you I think that's what
we're all about as well highlighting
good people in sport and they're just
two of the nicest people yeah they're
very nice and um very gentleman I
think very interesting game against bch
2494 yeah yeah he's playing really great
and he's taking his time yeah very very
weird
setup yeah he sacrificed this is the
game he sacrificed the pawn right yeah
yeah and F6
wow yeah they like to play
F6 yeah it didn't work for a couple of
previous improvers but maybe go as well
for
him yeah there is the
chance okay everybody thinking now it's
good I don't have any move to
play yeah in the beginning every you had
like five moves a second on every board
right it it almost seemed like they were
going to flag
you santanu borak from
India also mostly mostly all of the
people here are rapid players uh not so
much Blitz and bullet very few actually
play
bullet
okay do you do you do you play uh
sometimes faster than bullet like hyper
or
Ultra I was playing a lot like one year
ago two year ago against Andrew tang and
niski we were playing 30 seconds and it
was we were playing like we were
starting at 12: and we were finishing at
6:00 in the morning at least for me it
was not a bit Fair because I live in
Europe and they live in America so I had
to adjust my time but at the end I
couldn't feel my hand anymore my wrist
was going out
so um but nowadays I don't play so
much and how did you fair against them
at 30
seconds I I had positive for in the
beginning for instance four years ago
they were just crushing me but last one
two years I think still if you're better
in Chas than your opponents still it
will help you even in 30 second games so
okay okay yeah I managed to catch up
with them in the scores I was beating
them regularly at least but before that
I had no chance because my chess was not
so much better than them and they are
very quicker than me
so now they're just may maybe a bit
quicker than me but I'm much better than
them in chess so that helps yeah because
uh once you get that Gap uh you know in
quality it's it's uh completely
different playing one plus zero than one
plus one right exactly yeah one plus one
you can like do do
whatever yeah I think the best player
until now is J J berazzi he's putting a
lot of
pressure maybe he's even better beat I
don't know uh which one did you say JB
RI 343 okay let me just
check J bazzi 343 from United
States
y uh he plays everything like literally
everything he plays Bullet rapid uh
Blitz uh Atomic chess uh antichess uh
like everything what is ATI I don't know
I've never tried it a doesn't sound like
a very friendly
name yeah uh I'm pretty sure I've tried
it once but I can't remember what it
does it's like isn't it like uh you have
to lose all your pieces or no maybe it's
not uh I can't remember and you have
like the atomic chest when you grab a
piece everything around that piece
explodes
right so yeah pretty
crazy yeah an CH has over 41 Game King
of the Hill 62
games I've also never played King of the
Hill but yeah Atomic chess 138
games correspondence he also plays
correspondence yeah J bre is definitely
the the
man
yeah he plays everything he got bored of
real chess I think yeah yeah he mastered
it and then he took on other
challenges how many games
left um uh you have 10 wins and 10 are
still playing okay nice zero draws zero
loss
very nice let's go you've eliminated 50%
of the
competition nice just as the video
predicted yeah did you did you see that
video we posted I don't know if you saw
it we had your face on Chuck Norris's
body and you were just beating up drug
anyone that would come at
you no I didn't see that I should see it
afterwards yeah it was uh very nicely
done very very old
school
nice all
right I think I never lost the SE that I
was playing alone and the most Simo I
played was against 40 people in Qatar I
think like four years
ago 40 people huh yeah yeah I didn't
lose any game and it was interesting
format like when I was winning I I was
coming back like I won the game we shook
hands and when I came back they made
this chessboard again and I was playing
again with
them because I was like we put one day
just for this so I was bored kind of in
this country and I was just playing with
them a lot so it was
interesting bam still in the
game against de de dagio I'm in big
trouble I think now yeah dagio is our
number one improver right now so he's
obviously been improving his game a lot
by using the app yeah actually I'm in
big
trouble let's go
dagio against dagio oh wow that is stuff
happening there
definitely
yeah I think I'm close to get M I should
make some miracle happen here
well if anyone can do
it
ah not
easy I need to bring back the bishop I
think
you're going to stay on this board for a
while
huh
yes
patience yeah but it's it's interesting
okay uh there are some positions that
okay a lot of people can win but when
you say like it's
winning uh that doesn't necessarily mean
that everyone would win
it right uh it's in every level it's
like this like whenever stockfish for
instance Magnus also cannot win
sometimes and stockfish says
yeah but uh the position is objectively
winning
I
think he might be able to pull this
off all the games that are remaining
are very
interesting well now will be the Moment
of Truth uh so still 10
playing very
nice am I mewing I I have no idea what
the the the word Mee
is like the
Pokemon no I I I don't think that's what
he
meant is is there a like a word are you
meing like
what behaving like a
Pokemon like a
Pokemon
bch2 24 is playing very creative
CH
but we'll see if it will work out for
him
okay I finished one game against
aikara and nobody's moving that's good
news he probably meant that I was
meowing like a cat no I I don't think
that's
it mewing is the jaw exercise to
increase jawline
definition unless unless you can do it
via playing chess uh not not so much
no how would one do
that mewing is acting like a
cat yeah I think so this
is I heard about
this we no I don't think I I think
they're tricking us uh into believing
that I don't think that's a real
thing I'm sure I will at least make draw
in one of the
games yeah but it is very rare that uh
you know someone gets 40 wins yeah yeah
or or 20
or okay I finished the game
with you put you put your tongue on the
roof of your mouth and press down with
your
jaw I don't think you're going in good
plac yeah I don't understand
no I have no idea what that is I think I
keep my tongue at the roof of my mouth
always that's how you breathe through
your nose properly it true oh yeah yeah
like mine just sits
there so we are always moing now now now
I'm constantly thinking how it's always
there yeah it's it's there even now as
soon as I stop talking it's there we'
we've had a couple uh questions Ali Resa
what's your favorite football team who
do you support soccer right yeah um
now I I'm supporting many team but
Liverpool was my
childhood team but they are now going
downgrading so I think Real Madrid is
very strong it's good to support the
winners
always because they always
win Al your favorite team is who is
winning now yes and now I am in the mood
that I don't want to support for losing
team
anymore because I supported everybody
that was against Real Madrid and they
always win so I give
up
yeah Devo is finishing here the
game can he do
it I think he's made in few
moves um or he will win a lot of
material yeah nasty stuff is
coming
exactly but he should keep his com here
do you do you feel like you do you know
like where you've made some serious
error or something or was it just simple
outplaying I think I made the serious
errors once in one position but I will
go back to it
because uh let me check
theia yeah yeah uh it was King Indian
attack and I made a mistake
around
oh sorry I got
another when I where I exchang the
pieces there it was not a good exchange
so okay okay I I underestimated his
Knight on G3 that is very strong yeah
that is a that is a
monster
MH yeah he's giving the check now he has
to
decide what what what he wants to take
yes he decided to take my Rook yeah it's
a good idea good decision
yeah but I believe he's he's very
underrated if this is his real rating no
it's not uh because he probably maybe
plays on chess.com or maybe he doesn't
play online at all because he has a
question
mark oh okay
yeah he played rapid and also classical
here oh no Blitz he has Blitz he played
over 856
games oh but he plays unrated
games yeah that's why he has a question
mark on
rating uhuh okay well I mean he is our
number one improver so yeah he has
that's that's why yeah he has everyone
else you could become this good he has
over a thousand
games how many do you have ala like a
100 thou maybe
200,000 un Lees yeah uh I don't know I
think I just have against nitki 100,000
games yeah yeah with with ultra
bullet yeah because my account got
reseted once and I lost my game streak
and it was at around 70,000 at that
point
oh that's that's a lot yeah I also
that's even more than me probably couple
of years I I did the you know D into the
dark arts of hyper bullet uh you were
playing yeah nice actually oh sorry de
dagio blundered his Rook here but he's
take could take that's a very lucky
blunder by
dagio ah he could have blundered or
maybe it wasn't the the blunder maybe he
went for maybe he's trading down into a
maybe winning end game yeah yeah yeah he
maybe he missed night D1 check he could
have kept his rook and his Knight he
missed Knight D1 check but he still he's
winning yeah but now it's a now it's an
end game
right I was just talking uh in my
previous video about should I make a
tutorial on how to win an end game when
you're up a
piece right now we'll see how dagio or
maybe it's D action item
yeah how to do
it yeah I mean it is tricky because you
want to know how to do it most properly
you know like a true gentleman like
capablanca would do it like no
unnecessary
moves yeah I think the best technique of
all time probably is Corp of he was like
not giving any chance
yeah okay now it's uh now it's the past
B Pawn now it's
dangerous now it's getting close to draw
I see more I see more this game goes to
draw than losing I
think wow what a
game so he he sort of blundered but he
stumbled into a lucky
blunder
right yeah you you could blunder worse
at least you get a knight as a as a
consolation prize
exactly it's Magnus smurfing no I don't
think
so
yeah it wasn't a free rook it was a it
was a lucky exchange
sacrifice okay Bishop A6 very
nice
where is me Meo is downstairs he's
always always
chilling yeah he sacrifices The
Rook okay now if I change my Bishop for
his Knight probably it's losing so I
have to go to
back
now it's now it's all about King
speed if I manage to take off these
pawns for H3 and G6 one then it's easy
draw so that will be my plan can you
imagine somehow winning this
game you could always win G yeah you
could always
win
some sort of a some sort of a devious
devious
Checkmate sorry what was it okay King
F3 a eight
playing 12 wins eight zero draws zero
losses it's not
bad how's morphe
doing I think morphy is finished right
or has morphy
finished we're we're going to check on
him uh after this this is now the big
one this is the big one this
is
oh no I made draw oh
no I made draw against
Cooper loud Ste
mate really that's really
stupid I just I just preed all the moves
I calculated that the king lands on h8
when I go
F7
[Music]
oh oh nice so Cooper Willams gets a draw
against
alza
cooper cooper the legend the
legend that's really unfortunate for
me yeah okay uh one of the players uh
gets a good position against ala then he
can't focus so much on the others so you
know you're helping everyone
else he's really happy in the Lees
chat Demitri I am I am trying to confuse
him as much as possible can you not hear
me talking all this
nonsense Cooper is our number nine
improver on the leaderboard currently so
shout out to him and obviously made made
some good improvements over the past
month to be able to get this
draw but dagio what will is it dagi or
dagio what will he
doio is trying his
best nicely cutting of the white king
very nice
right but that bsh controlling the two
pawns and dark squares what a what a
menace yeah that's
my only hope that
P I should not allow second St mate in
in one of the
games
um should very be very careful against
the vaj to not lose do not run into a
fork
yep Knights are Knights are tricky
bastards
exctly no that Bishop is quite the
champion but I'm still going
strong bam
Almighty also playing all the all the
time formats and all the
variations
morph still in the game but with less
than two minutes on the clock and Jay
brzy Jay braz is finished almost it's
the last
move and but dagio is making he's
getting job done I think
s Simon
kacho very interesting position but six
seconds on the
clock which one Simon coo the one you
just
played okay okay this one's
uh this one's coming to an
end but now he got
forked
[Music]
unfortunately okay so Simon kachol loses
on
time yeah J BRZ is
finished uh three playing so 16 wins one
draw three
playing yeah I think I will lose the
last
game
I remember when I was playing when I was
playing against the Mastery in Simo I
hoped everyone else loses an ivy the
only person that gets good
result that's
the special
way so I'm sure the vagio will be very
you think that's what the vaju is hoping
as
well I think
so he would be he might be disappointed
I made one
draw Sor right let me
just but he has still some yeah and he
has
time okay most people following the
dagio
game question is should
I okay I will cut him off here even
morphe also with a very interesting
position
but Checkmate is coming and 10 seconds
on the
clock yeah morphy's position is
collapsing yeah that's
mate and it was a very good game only
dagio left yeah one playing 18 wins one
draw one loss sorry zero
losses it will be soon one loss so it's
okay let's see I will try my best to not
lose should use all my tricks
here what's a what's a good trick you
can use
here
uh I think I should put my
Bishop somewhere that is very tricky
like maybe on
H2 oh he he he knew he knew you would do
that he Prem moved
it yeah okay he's
trying this
say I will go back to my
home
all right we'll see if he can do it in
in two two and a half
minutes I'm actually not sure if it's
winning already but I might be
wrong it's very interesting
this I will actually try to study it
after I don't
know h
guess he has to somehow cut off my
Bishop like put the Knight on G3 and
trap my Bishop so I have no choice just
to exchange yeah then I will bring but
when he goes like King G2 in the right
moment I have to bring my king to F5 so
when he takes my Bishop I take the pawn
andj the
draw you
see it's probably do to Advan
this
but he has to somehow just put take the
push the pawn to G2 somehow he has to
make it happen he has to make moves he's
already down to a minute and a
half King E4 is a really good
move so the question is if I go King to
E1 or the other
side you will you will have to tell us I
think I have to bring around
now it's already probably draw whenever
I try to solve an end game I try to go
where I don't want to
go yeah
exactly it's always some silly
move it's exactly why we have the end
gamees attribute and improve
right in games are really
annoying but
deaj is trying his
best okay he said he settled for draw
said enough is
enough right but was it let me just
check uh yeah pretty much at any depth
uh leas says leas super engine says it's
a draw it's a draw
okay I can let it go deeper maybe it
figure something out
but but in the end game the depth
doesn't matter the even very low engine
will safe it's draw it's draw
so
really yeah in the end games that are
like two pieces three pieces left is
book uh table base right yeah if it has
access table bases yeah yeah of course
yeah yeah
okay I
think the best player was the
vaj in this I was certainly very close
to lose okay but don't take anything
from the other draw as well I mean it
was uh he fought he fought until end so
yeah but the V was winning against me so
he gets cooper cooper whims uh he he
knew you would pre moove and then he
caught you into a
Perpetual right so that was uh that was
you know showing of true genius yeah
mental fortitude there we love that
exactly all right so uh which one do you
think it was the the best game the one
that we've just seen against
dagio I think so by uh I think by far
this was the best game that was played
he played really impressive like I I
played the best opening against Kings
Indian probably and then he really out
played me at some
point and I blundered so I think he
deserves to be called the best
game yeah and you were really really
better for the entire
game yeah yeah and I but he put his
Knight on G3 which is
very tricky always until end of the game
so
he played a really really nice game I
think yeah even even a strong strong guy
like yourself is not immune to you know
having your opponent's Knight on G3
close to your king like that no it's not
easy to manage
it was uh how was the General experience
was uh was it at all exhausting for you
to play like this I was expecting people
people take more their time more their
time huh right because I think just five
four five people took their time to
think other people they just played
really
quickly
so um if they would have take their time
would have been more challenging but
still it was really challenging
especially against the vagio so um I
think has made an appearance in the
chat nice he said his Rook Rook
sacrifice was on purpose a rook
sacrifice was on purpose oh really okay
then he missed Knight D1 check okay then
he missed Knight D1 check that he could
keep his Rook so that makes
sense okay maybe he didn't miss it maybe
he maybe that's what he really was
planning yeah that is what he's saying
right in the chat
yeah we will believe
him yeah Knight C1 strongest move always
with always a move with the Knight back
that's uh right if you don't if you
don't see Knight D1 cheick probably
Knight D5 is the best move actually
yeah makes sense cuz it it is winning
but you still have to work hard for
it
right so when uh when uh when are you
traveling ala for the big
event right I need to go to of man in 2
three days and then I will go to America
for one month and then I will go to
Canada for I will I will leave home on
20 of October I will come back in
Christmas so it's a long
travel okay so it's not like you're
you're completely out of Chess you still
will play some
chess I will play a lot of Chess this
second half of I you play almost every
day second half so of the year that's
always the schedule like first half I
take some rest to get ready for second
half cuz I know second half is very
crazy so uh will we be playing the the
world rapid and
Blitz yeah I heard it will be in January
so I will try to play there in
January yeah I think so it will be I
heard at least from what I heard is in
January mid beginning of January oh but
it's a good thing it's a good thing they
will not put it in during Christmas and
New Year anymore
yeah every day is from Christmas till
New Year yeah and ruining
everyone's everyone's vacation and stuff
yeah I don't think I've ever heard of it
uh not being played during that
time but it's a good change if they make
so what do you what do you have to do to
to qualify for the for the next
candidates tournament where is uh where
is the the
event yeah I have to callif for is of
men in is of men otherwise in rating me
and hikaro we are the only like not only
but the biggest competitor because other
guys are 20 ratings down so me and hiar
we have the same rating exactly and we
have to see who will end the marathon
right finish the marathon
first ah to qualify we are the highest
rating yeah also they will have one spot
for that still right yeah there's one
spot for that ah so H how do you stop
the other guy from playing like a 100
games against his uh
teammate sorry I mean what what if
someone just plays like 10 games against
someone uh like in one day to increase
the
rating oh okay that's not likely someone
will do it because it will F will accept
will F accept to make it rated these
kind of things yeah I mean ding had to
do it to qualify for the candidates
tournament and then he played
like I don't know how many games in one
one event it was specifically organized
for
him yeah I mean that's not a nice way to
qualify but but I mean it's I like
because I there should be rating spot
because otherwise rating will not mean
anything if they don't put it so but
maybe they have to find a way for they
have to find the solution for this but
but but um I will not probably do this
so yeah okay but still Magnus is still
the highest rating if he decides you
know last minute he wants to play yeah
but Magnus is qualified from World Cup
so he's oh he's qualified from World Cup
yeah he's qualified all
around yeah it's now just me andaru
left and uh with with the Grand Prix uh
uh is it two or three spots from the
Grand Prix yeah the grand s in I of man
is two spots ah two spots so yeah for
instance if hikaro qualifies is a good
thing for
me okay but but you are looking forward
to playing in the
candidates yeah exactly everybody um I
will I want to try because especially if
I win I will be the youngest world
champion this year so this will be the
last shot I think to become youngest but
anyway it's a Well youngest is Kasparov
at 21 yeah yeah I will have the same age
so before him it was tall with 22 Yeah
right and so on yeah yeah so this will
be my last year but um it's said it's
something that should happen with L I
think like there could be Corona Corona
took two years from me so it's I don't
put it's not my goal to be youngest
because it's not really fair because
forance Corona comes and it takes two
years it's what you can do
right did you improve a whole lot during
coid um I think the fact I just didn't
lose my mind during Co was a win
[Music]
so because you lose your mind if you're
too much at home
right yeah
definitely
uh I have a I have a question from one
of our app members do you have have time
for one Blitz game
alza against who against his
son what is his
name uh let me just
check
uh I'm pretty sure it's let me just
check uh I think it's this one
yeah it's uh Ian
ianco okay I could play while you ask me
your questions okay so challengeing
one can you send me on Twitter the name
yeah I can send it to you I can send it
to you
okay I
just uh sorry where is where is my
Twitter there it
is okay there you
go okay nice he's not online
even oh he will be probably in a in a
few
seconds
okay let me just check I will challenge
him do you know him yeah yeah he's my
nephew oh
okay there we
go I challenge team
so ah sorry sorry wrong son this one is
not at
home all right I'll uh send you the the
the real link uh is this one yeah I'm
pretty sure it is yeah this is the one
all
right did you uh yeah yeah I sent you
the the handle to to to to the wrong
son
okay
challenge I am challenging
him
yeah the wrong sound what are you going
to
do clay do you have any any additional
questions for ala while we're
waiting um I don't have any questions
personally I mean if the chat wants to
ask any questions happy to to have him
answer those but I mean
I mainly just wanted to say you know
thank you for for doing this alza I mean
I've learned about a lot about you over
the past month and you know your story
is is super inspiring and you seem like
such a such a good person and exactly
the type of person we want to work with
so I really appreciate your time and and
wish you the best of luck and and lastly
I'll just say you know the improvers
over the past month we've gotten a lot
of messages about how inspirational
you've been in in their lives in their
chess journey and especially a lot of
Iranians who say you know you're such an
inspiration to them and you know just
all all of those types of good comments
so you know thank you for for being you
and again it's a pleasure to work with
you yeah thanks thanks I'm also happy to
be working with you guys Antonio of
course I know him I met him in Croatia
actually and um it's great to be working
with you guys
also Mori is asking how he could have
played better is there any
is there any tip you could give
him what game was
Mor you don't you don't remember all of
them uh let
me let make let me make my brain worker
here here's a simpler one who's your
favorite world chess
champion besides you besides besides you
in this year are coming up here I think
I learned from from everyone but Magnus
for instance was because when I started
Chas he became world champion that year
so I would be lying if I don't say that
I'm I didn't look up to him so but I
liked Kasparov a lot I liked um Fisher a
lot so but probably I learned most from
Magnus because I started him as being
world champion I think the exact same
moment that he became world Champion I
kind of started chess
so
probably he's one of my favorites so
it's and it's very
logical yeah I think it's it's like that
with a lot of
people
yeah but I didn't imagine that I will be
competitor against him one
day it happened all it happened all too
quick yeah that was the same experience
for me when I found myself on the court
with Novak jokovic I was just like how
did I get here this is so this is so
cool when was the when was the first
time you played him
2015 okay 2015 2016 it was probably
either late 2015 or early
nice well corus I heard he's a very big
fan of Chess
also who alaras oh alcaras really oh I
didn't hear I didn't know that that's
that's very cool yeah he plays chess he
made the interview he plays chess all
always before a big game just to relax
his mind
and I love
that
yeah feder's coach as you probably
Antonio told you he's big fan of Chess
he's from Catia I know is good friends
with him it's a lubic right
right yeah yeah I used to I used to
watch lubich a lot as a kid he was I
mean he was in his prime kind of when I
was I don't know probably like in my
early teens or maybe even before that he
was he was a really fun player to
watch and he's really really strong in
chess
now I could imagine yeah I I I think he
could very well be like maybe over over
2100 Le
chess
wow yeah because he he he improves very
very rapidly and very
systematically like he he he really
approaches uh every every chess game
like like a
professional right yeah well I think
that's a little bit of the you know it's
it's it's a it's a competitor's mindset
that you learn from playing any game at
a high level and um you know that's
that's a lot of what we try to teach on
improve as well is just you know how to
get into that mindset and how to have a
mindset that when you play you're
actually aware enough of what's
happening so that you can improve upon
it I I've seen in my experience you know
a lot of people who kind of stay at that
intermediate level in whatever game
they're playing they just they don't
really have the mental awareness of
what's going on like they'll lose and
then it's like okay let's just play
another one like they don't really learn
anything from it
right I think for sure there's some
connection between chess and Tennis
because
um a lot of chess players like tennis a
lot of tennis players like chess so
there should be some connection there
that maybe is even s scientific right y
yeah but I think that uh tennis is even
more impressive than chess in one regard
is that in in chess okay if your
position is bad doesn't matter how well
you play you will lose it but in tennis
it doesn't matter how bad your position
is if you start playing better than your
opponent there's no way for him to force
a
win that's true I don't know if that's
possible in tennis for someone to
actually you know just you know be
losing two two zero and then just you
know start completely winning no I mean
I I've yeah I've had matches before
where I've been down I mean one comes to
mind specifically I was down 06 so
didn't win a single game in the first
set and then was down 25 in the second
set and I remember sitting on the
sideline just being like all right well
what am I going to have for dinner
tonight this is going to be over quick
and then an hour and a half later I won
the match yeah yeah okay that that's not
possible in chess yeah like if you're
down a queen uh okay you can make it
difficult but uh doesn't matter how how
well you play if your opponent same same
thing in football I mean if you're down
10 Zer in the 90th minute there's no way
you're coming back great yeah because
there's no time limit in chess in
tennis yeah is there like have they
invented something like Blitz tennis or
bullet
tennis um not with timing no nothing
it's never done anything based on time
so they are experimenting with a format
right now where you only play four games
in a set instead of six uh just to kind
of speed things up because you know it's
gotten to the point now where you see
alcaraz and jokovic they play a five and
a half hour match in the finals of
Australia and it's kind of like on one
end it's a lot to ask physically from
the players on the other end it's a lot
to ask from The Spectators to sit on
their couch for five and a half
hours yeah I heard in tennis they want
to also like make the games a bit lower
like less time but people don't agree
with it right what's your take on
that sorry I'm you say you said in
tennis right right yeah yeah um my take
is I'm kind of a traditionalist I I like
the three out of five sets I I mean I
personally would like to watch a 5H hour
match of jokovic and alcarez it's like
the highest level of sport and you know
physical activity that you could
possibly watch so I personally love it
but you know the the younger younger
kids you know people don't have
attention spans the way they used to so
I see the value in it um in speeding
things up um but personally I I'm a
traditionalist so I would prefer it to
stay the same yeah yeah yeah I also
enjoy like whenever for instance jovic
playing it against ERS you want to see
them play Until the End they have like
whatever they have right so yeah I mean
I want to see them you know the cool
part about tennis for me is when you're
you know at that point where you're
exhausted you're you're exhausted
physically and mentally and like that's
where you have to like dive to the
deepest levels of of what you have to to
try to come out with a win I mean if you
if you shorten the match then you never
get to a point where jokovic feels like
he's exhausted right
exactly okay Al you have one more
challenge
okay oh man you're really working him
hard yeah I mean he he got off easy on a
couple of those
games couple of a couple of simal games
were over in like uh five
moves yeah yeah it's okay I could play
with your cousin
now no this one this next one is
actually my my
brother-in-law Goron no no he's brother
brother
okay you sent me yeah yeah I've sent you
on Twitter okay
okay all right let's see
it but uh Philip Philip got a draw it
was a very nice what was it the B Gambit
right he played some B it was very
strange game but I yeah he's a he's a
bko
specialist how old is
he uh
16 okay no he's really talented I think
the way he played at least was very
impressive you're giving me tough
challenges here
yeah the the Sim was a
warmup now I'm going to go through
through the game and
uh uh check out what what what really
happened on the boards and the the
nicest one obviously the one that you
you have chosen I'm going to show that
on the
channel I don't even know how how Qatar
Masters finished our stream just started
uh while the two Notre Becks were
playing for for first place yeah I think
yaku have won the championship ah he did
I think so I just saw a tweet so if I
didn't read it
wrong who do you like alza from from the
really younger
generation those that are young younger
even than you who do you see as a like a
really big
Prospect I think everyone from India is
good everyone h uh right I don't see so
much difference between them like they
calculate good they make the best moves
and um
but sometimes one guy in India will play
better than other but in general I don't
see so much difference they're all very
good they will
definitely be they're already in top but
they will become for sure top 10 and
these kind of things so it's a new I
think I think generation is getting
changed slowly slowly yeah I think gash
and prag are already number 13 and
number
14 okay
yeah so it's already changed for
instance oron dropped so it's amazing to
see how slowly everything is changing
right the
generation yeah only Anand remains
always in top
10 yeah because probably he doesn't play
so much and he's really good he's like
his what they say like what's your score
against
him I I played him once in y can Z four
years ago and I lost In
classical so ah and in other formats you
haven't
played uh in Zagreb this year I played
bleit against team I won
rapid was I don't remember if rapid I
won or I draw I didn't lose certainly so
I don't remember maybe it was draw or I
won
so but it's amazing I don't know if when
I'm 53 I will be playing like
this is it 53 yeah it is
53 I think he is 53
yeah yeah but you seen kaid
in in K chess he's 64 and he yeah
obliterated Jordan with the with Bishop
captur on
H7 right and also very well uh he played
very well against
Magnus
yeah he's he was also a legend
so uh how how how was this game you
won yeah he definitely he played worse
than than your nephew
but but still it was interesting G yeah
he's he's the strongest one in the
family how they got all in the chest
because of you right no no no oh their
father he like plays chess non-stop he
plays chess his entire life everyone
like the entire plays
chess new Indian
generation a m generation yeah we'll see
we'll
see okay ala if you want you can take
some other challenges if you're if
you're if you're uh you know too tired
from all the stressful Oppo you know
chest from all all those impressive
opponents uh we will not bother you
anymore I could I could take one more
Challenge and then I need to go work on
my chest to not lose all the a in O of
man okay you you you choose uh all right
so uh I'm going to send you okay uh you
can use the first link that I've that
I've sent you the the one that that was
not
available okay
okay someone you have someone that you
already chose Antonio what yeah yeah we
already tried him but he was not
available yeah this the person that
Goron's saying in chat is is a good user
of improve as well
yeah and they they're they're they're
also a part of the team so to say
they're they're always helping Gan
polish everything up oh great well shout
out to ivanco then thank
you uh oh they're already playing wow
super fast what what was
this I'm trying to play some
Peak
okay Sebastian fer brand says alza is a
nice
person thank you seen a lot of those
comments today I
agree no he says what a nice person it's
like he he thought you weren't and now
he's like wow this ala is actually a
nice
person who' know
the problem is that for instance when
I'm in the tournaments I don't give so
much signature so probably like when I
have tournaments I don't give signatures
and these kind of things so people think
I'm very I'm kind of a rude person but
it's just like professional life you
don't have time for this when you have
to go to the game and these kind of
things
so yeah that was always one of my big
complaints too is people just they just
don't understand I mean obviously we
love the the fans and you know for me
like the fans are a huge reason why I'm
playing is because I appreciate their
support but if you come up to me 15
minutes before I'm about to walk on the
court like I I don't want to talk to you
like I'm sorry yeah yeah we have enough
in our mind right
at but of course for them it's special
moment also so it's understandable for
instance if I meet um jovic so 15
minutes before the game yeah I'd
probably be like hey
man yeah that's the
problem so it yeah people have their
rituals before a match you can just
uh impose on them like
that right someone says ala are you
going to be a fashion
designer um it's not very likely now I'm
just very focused on chess so but I
tried it it was interesting experience
but um for now I'm just focusing on for
playing these two three tournaments then
I will get back probably and uh but now
I just my mind is in chess right maybe
create some exclusive chess
wear yeah I will definitely make this
yeah
like can the leavon can be your your
model he loves he loves wearing stuff he
loves he loves different colors yeah
yeah he's always the most colorful one
in the room right he he's the well Dred
man
okay so is done very nice Ian Esco but
uh not today so out of the out of the
three of them uh one gu got a
draw right and nice very nice it's a
very good
result yeah all right so ala thank you
very much for uh gracing us with your
presence on our first event for improve
uh it was very entertaining and very
educational uh I I I enjoyed it very
much I I didn't think it would be over
that fast uh even though some of the
players lasted a bit longer uh but uh
yeah you're you're you're a very good
chess player what are you going to do
yeah thanks guys for having me it was a
pleasure to talk to you guys and it was
something I I took something from tennis
from you Antonio it was good yeah also
some someone asked me to ask you in the
chat will you be watching uh Islam
versus makev the the the
fight it's tonight yeah I think it is
yeah yeah yeah I think I will I will buy
it yeah I will watch it probably yeah
for me it's tomorrow morning butth yeah
I'm also going to watch it right right
okay yeah we'll probably watch I watch
all the
sports well thank you so much ala this
was a pleasure to to talk with you and
thank you agad matur for streaming and
shout outs to again dagio and Cooper our
our two draws it's a amazing performance
and we hope everyone else enjoyed the
show and hopefully uh we'll join us for
our next event as well we're trying to
put on a lot of these um and again our
goal is to grow the chess Community grow
the chess game and we're always looking
uh for ways to do that so thank you all
for joining us and if you don't mind
could you end the stream by playing the
uh the Youtube video that that we
optimized just
the not at all not at all just give me a
second we can just end it with that so
everyone can get it get an idea for
improving what we're trying to do
uh it's this one
yeah uh I can't see yet cuz the stream's
a little bit delayed but it's it's the
the one with the white
[Music]
background
n
sorry uh muted my mic for a second
there
yeah uh that was it uh that that was the
one you were referring to
yeah uh yeah still haven't seen it just
because the stream's so delayed but
hopefully uh I shouldn't be that delayed
I I said it oh maybe I'm a little bit
behind yeah I think you're behind it's
yeah yeah perfect yeah yeah you played
the right one maybe like 15 seconds yeah
yeah yeah you played the right one all
right yeah uh thank you everyone for
joining us thank you clay for uh staying
for the entire event it was pleasure
having you here uh you really know your
way with the audience
uh must be from all those talks with
your your friends playing um all sorts
of games yeah yes exactly yeah uh it was
a real pleasure and uh I hope we will be
able to do something like this very soon
yeah look out for many more events and
um again we're going to be constantly
adding content to the improve app that's
that's all approved by a gmor and we had
two people draw against Ali Resa today
that were in the top 10 of our improved
leaderboard so obviously they're
learning something from the app and we
hope everyone else can download and and
learn something as well yeah it was a
much better result than I expected to
tell you the truth yeah all right thank
you everyone thank you clay and uh until
next time till next time